okay great now on to the ufo question
brian when you say that scientists have
an incentive to find life in the
universe and incentives via nobel prize
in money etc i don't buy that per se i
think they have an incentive to find a
certain form of life in the universe but
not life in general and the reason is
that life in general borders on what is
considered to be woo or paranormal for
example if you were to study ufos and
say is there credibility to these these
reports that's almost not done besides a
few individuals like kevin knuth for
example
because i
i i think almost none of us i don't
think any of us are actually pursuing
the truth including myself which is why
i don't like when people say this
channel's for truth seekers almost none
of us care about the truth per se
because the truth can be extremely hard
so we care about it in a certain bounded
fashion so we also care about our
reputations we care about not sounding
like these d in sensate to cerebrate
rednecks which is what the people in the
academy generally think of those who who
consider the ufo reports to be real they
they generally consider them to and
let's be honest they consider them to be
kooks and i think that academics
generally care much more about either
sounding intelligence or not appearing
to be inane
more than they care about the truth per
se and so it's it's extremely bounded by
their
either place in a social hierarchy by
their place among their peers they don't
want to be ostracized it's anathema to
analyze ufo reports so that's why i say
i don't buy
when
you say that well we have an extreme
incentive to find life in the universe a
certain type of life i agree
yeah well i think uh i think largely
that is accurate although i will say in
my defense you know i did join the
galileo project with our mutual friend
navi loeb
specifically for this reason not as a
researcher but as a member of the
external oversight board because i
actually don't think they need my help
as an observational astronomer i'm
pretty good but you know harvard is not
exactly hurting for for money and
you know they can certainly raise
funding especially when you have the you
know uh former uh chairman the
longest-serving chairman in harvard's
history in the astronomy department at
the helm who's you know joe rogan's
appearance blew up the internet and uh
has has uh you know number five
bestseller um you know last year in the
new york times list so i don't think
they need my help you know kind of
necessarily doing the research but i do
think they can always use help uh
holding them to account
and you know if i i told this to avi you
know i wouldn't have called it the
galileo project i think it's dangerous
when you know uh astronomers begin uh by
you know kind of bringing up the names
like bruno and and galileo and and
persecuted
figures in history i think that's a
fraught perilous endeavor and i think i
would be even that is sort of a be lying
a bias in other words his his claim is
that just like galileo uh suffered from
and the inability of the powers that be
the funding agencies of this time the
venetian doge and senate and and other
agencies to at first look through in the
catholic church later on to look through
his telescope and and see for themselves
as if that would have proven anything i
mean just looking through a telescope
proves nothing it's the connection of
the human mind and the formulation of a
hypothesis and evidentiary data that
could disconfirm his hypothesis you know
galileo had many blunders kurt uh i'm
pleased and privileged to be working
with uh with jim gates carlo revelli
frank wilczyk fabiola giannatti and my
good friend from uh from uh graduate
school lucio picarillo on the first ever
audiobook version of any of galileo's
book and it's oh that's interesting and
i also didn't know that that was the
genesis of the word galileo in the
project i thought it just meant i'm
going to be looking out like galileo
looked down no no i mean i i think the
project's really dangerous i'd like to
kind of push back on you i mean not push
back i'd like to reassure you i mean i
can't speak for brian just a second just
a second lee i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i
just want brian to finish because i i
interrupted him and then so please
finish brian and then and then leave
kurt's used to me interrupt him
but uh so we're translating galileo's
book we have the rights to the first
ever audiobook for galileo uh with a
forward by einstein and uh that's read
by frank wilcheck winner of the nobel
prize in 2004 and jim gates so what does
it say it says galileo was wrote the the
definitive treatise on the scientific
method on what you're supposed to do
with evidence etc etc and yet in that
very book he makes a catastrophic
confirmation blunder at the very end on
day four it's a trialog between these
three characters i'm one of them carlo
revelli's another one and my friend
lucio's the other and we go about and
we're trying to disprove uh galileo's
character salviati is trying to disprove
uh the uh the the earth-centered notion
of the universe that's held by simplicio
the simpleton uh who is espousing the
words of the pope uh that the earth is
the center of the universe and then i'm
playing segreto the kind of
knowledgeable lay person who is
interpreting between them and gal is a
phenomenal writer but he goes through
and describes these things in such
loving detail that even i become
convinced when he goes about and says
that the tides on the earth are proof
that the earth is going around uh the
sun that's complete balderdash we know
that's not correct and it would take
newton to do it and his argument is very
simple and persuasive it uses data it
would have gotten accepted by nature
probably if nature had existed not like
you know lee's travails um but his
argument is that you've got this you
know you've got this object that's going
around the sun here's the sun over here
and here we've got tides on the earth
and uh as it goes around the sun it
orbits and the tide sloshes around and
that's why we have ti it's totally wrong
the tides are caused by the lunar
gravitational force the tidal force
quadripolar moment of the lunar
gravitational force field nothing to do
with our motion around the sun really
and yet it's incredibly persuasive and
so if you took the lessons of absolute
objective history and you say like
should we have listened to galileo no
you throw out that book you throw it out
he says nonsense even though that he
brings up relativity for the first time
in human history the notion of relative
motion does not affect the laws of
nature which we now call a rents and
variants these are foundational things
and yet the summary of the book is
totally wrong the conclusion of the book
is totally misproven and he didn't use
the best evidence in hand so look for
that coming soon hopefully on galileo's
birthday in february but
this is all to say when it comes to when
it comes to avi's project avi loeb's
project um i think they need oversight
more than they need my insight which is
to say that i think the the first
reaction that we have to have is
skepticism because we do want to believe
i think if we all go back to our 12 year
old boys when we were 12 year old boys
forget about funding and and i'm gonna
lose my my my status as a chair
professor or leigh's gonna lose no we're
just little boys and we're playing with
that little pebble on the beach like
ninten said and we're looking for a
shinier pebble if we were to discover
that i mean it raises the hair in the
back of my neck that there was
extraterrestrial intelligence first life
you know i i have my misgivings i've
talked to lee about that we'll talk
about that some other just about slime
mold on the planet enceladus or the moon
enceladus i don't think that will make
as big an impact as lee does but let's
leave that aside let's just talk about
ufos i
don't want to believe i want to have
evidence and i think if you if you bury
your head in the sand you won't get
evidence so i have to say
and i hope this is true of avi too uh
that we are kind of the poi boy the 12
year old boys sitting on the on the bed
not being able to fall asleep at night
looking up at the stars we do want to
know the truth but we want to have
evidence for it as mature men as
scientists at this very moment so anyway
lee you were going to say you've got
some problems with with uh with the
project and i'm happy again i don't
speak for them i'm on their external
advisory committee i think it's
important to do but i am predisposed
it's like the bets that stephen hawking
used to make with kip thorne he would
bet against hawking radiation ever being
you know validated and uh so that if he
lost a bet you know he'd have the thrill
of intellectual superiority being
correct
uh so what say you lee
yeah i mean it's no big it's no big deal
i'm i think i'm i've got a lot of
sympathy for kurt's position
or kind of um worry about where we are
as scientists look for ufos but i think
that i know avi very well he's great but
he's playing a very strange game here i
would like to say he's kind of saying oh
the scientific establishment's not ready
for this i'm a genuine conterrian and
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna basically
come up with these things i'm being
ignored no he's just making stuff up
right making stuff up what is he making
up a theo location with leon cronin and
avi love is about to be booked we got a
plan yeah so what i mean by is making
stuff up he's making up a
false argument about um
that people are kind of you know when it
comes to this interstellar object that
came through and he was just he was
saying why it could be alien space junk
sure it could be all sorts of things but
but we were trying to understand
what the characteristics of trajectory
was telling us so he's kind of making up
stories which are fine i don't mean he's
fabricating stuff i mean he's saying a
narrative and i'm wondering why is he
making that narrative what does he have
to gain
other than some kind of you know fame
and notoriety and i'm going to be
downtrodden by the establishment because
if i suddenly said to brian hey brian
we've just found wormholes i saw it over
there look wormhole over there wormhole
over there wormhole over there and and
then brian says lee you haven't got any
wormholes you just make you know you
haven't got any date and i'd be like
you're just beating me up big professor
you know and i think it's a bit like
this so well i i'm really glad that
brian that is kind of borderline ad
hominem lee i have to point that out i
mean i love avi i fight with avi but but
that seems like imputing his impugning
his character almost you can
disassociate yourself from it what i'm
trying to say to so it's not clipped out
of context is that i like the idea of
searching
but i there is this so what i'm trying
to say there's this cultural vibe going
on right now our culture is changing
people are asking questions what are
these things that the pentagon has
released what is the probability of us
this happening
and and i'm saying that we don't
we could play together i would love to
help avi be successful i it doesn't i
don't think it's a
we i don't think the establishment is
against him i don't think even i'm in
the establishment we genuinely want to
know and i do agree with you that there
is some
we are putting we could put our careers
on the line if we get it wrong but
actually in science you have become
better scientists the more you're wrong
and what i'm saying here is abby's
adopting an extreme viewpoint where he
may not allow himself to be wrong and
it's not an ad hominem i'm not saying
he's anything bad i'm not saying he's
doing anything dishonest i'm saying he's
making a narrative well let's be precise
so i had him on my show
and it was a wonderful episode and this
is long before i decided to join
and i said avi i don't believe that you
believe this is real that this
is an extraterrestrial and he says
and and i said because if you did you
happen to have access to a resource
that's highly complex has a lot of uh
has a lot of assembly behind it called
yuri milner who is a russian billionaire
and he's showered upon
you the potential as a leader of the
breakthrough starshot uh prize one of
the leaders uh this tremendous resource
so instead of sending you know ten to
the fourth uh cell phone cameras to
proxima century b
why don't you send one of them
at you know not even half the speed of
light not even ten percent of the speed
i'll just you know three four percent of
this people and catch up to omumu you
know what he said he said no no we don't
need to do that because when ruben
telescope which is the vera rubin uh uh
observatory in chile which is going to
be a phenomenal instrument it's designed
it was the original name was the
large-scale synoptic
survey telescope to survey the whole sky
with a huge cadence very quickly looking
for objects that are anomalous that
could do and he says that's one of the
dream machines for discovering we
already discovered one of them using pan
stars on hawaii um so we're going to
discover millions of these things i said
well avi you know i don't know if you
know about this but you know like uh you
know sometimes you know
things happen only once you know there's
an n of one problem that we talk about
and what if this yeah what if they are
abundant and what if there are forces
that conspire against in our solar
system just particularly not to the
cosmos to our solar system maybe the
lunar you know so tidal solar whatever
whatever it is um and it makes these
objects very very unlikely to ever be
seen again even though they're abundant
wouldn't you want to catch up to the
only one with all the resources you have
and he was sort of agnostic about it
that gave me some pause and that's one
of the things i'm going to push back on
as an external advisor but i i would you
know and i love you lee but but i don't
think he's doing it for fam i mean he
has an ego that's well known um he's he
has trouble controlling um you know
sometimes his passions for what he does
i think he's doing an incredible
valuable service but i just want to talk
about from the perspective as an
observational astronomer can
observational astronomers provide
information in the way that you've been
using it
about this phenomenon uh in other words
we survey the sky in all wavelength
bands 24 7 around the earth from
antarctica where i've been twice for two
months of my life uh
and uh to the north pole to space now
we've got jwst um what would it convince
a believer
to
give up the uh the expectations in other
words carl sagan said lack of evidence
is not evidence of absence or absence of
evidence so we can't but we can't we
also have to admit we have conserved
resources in finite time which is the
most prominent of all reasons
let me just come in quickly so i
completely agree we're all characters
right and i know everything is great
all i'm trying to say is um we i want
him to help i want him to succeed so
exactly i think my the only thing i
would comment here say how can we help
you let's help let's help you do this
right whatever you think the narratives
are it's capturing the day i do think we
have a responsibility though and it's
not an ad holmen it is kind of a bit way
in this
polarization in the time of covid
elections we do have a responsibility
for correctly framing the arguments
we're not leading people down the guard
up the garden path that's the only point
i'm getting at i mean being too
optimistic or being too high salesman
yeah exactly exactly that's all i mean
nothing else everything else is good so
what i would say to avi is like how can
we help you what i would say to kurt is
like
what do you think
science science mainstream science is
doing enough of you're finding
frustrating because you know i'm i'm a
i'm a cheap scientist in the regard
i want to know why i'm in the universe i
want to know why i'm here i want to have
meaning if there are aliens out there i
want to know it's not just the right
type of alien any will do me
any evidence um and and i think about
that
meaning from science and meaning from
life in the universe that might have to
be a part two uh kirk but but anyway
yeah i know we both want want we want
evidence right we don't want to just you
know just marginally and we only have
finite amount of time and and
intellectual time but don't forget you
know
our forgetting curve you know is peaking
i can tell you from experience in a few
years you're going to have trouble
remembering your kids names and you know
hopefully you know uh that'll stop but
uh but but we only have so much time for
attention to pay attention to things of
of of great import to us so i i you know
i guess the the subject is what what
else should we be doing we being
astronomers avi's not going to build you
know a a large hadron collider squared
you know look for uh interdimensional
aliens you know manipulating wormholes
to get here right he's an astronomer
he's a theorist by the way he's not an
observer so so i think he needs help uh
i think the the you know having you
involved you know from that perspective
but then how do we translate the
signatures from assembly from you know
can be how do we translate that into an
actionable metric that will allow us to
reduce our uncertainty getting back to
our rubric at the beginning of this
conversation
well let me answer
one direct thing i think we can do this
with image data and time series data and
one of the things that would be very
interesting is like if you take any
given image on this dimensionality and
let's say i mean kurt you've got
assembly in one second it's brilliant
right you can apply the same thing to
two-dimensional images and also time
series images of course you have to
define your axioms precisely like when
you're looking at how this image image
can be created it's very rare you see
like a straight edge in nature it just
doesn't happen right
yeah i mean and so i i think that's
right and i i what i would say um kurt
quickly is
i've looked at these pentagon images and
i spoke to someone who was responsible
for releasing some of them and i was
like are you just trying to basically
are you just were you bored one day or
did you need more funding or something
why did you do it they were like no
actually we genuinely think
public paid for this data in a way and
we're just throwing it out there so what
i when i try to get out of them what
they thought they wouldn't tell me so
what do you think of these images i mean
you must have i've looked at them i've
listened to people on podcasts on joe
rogan's podcast in particular and looked
at the data and there's all this
mischaracterization of different people
looking at different data sets and
saying things like there's this object
that i think brian you've talked about
this this this this uh this tic-tac that
went from supposedly you know um very
high up to 50 feet off the ocean in like
a second um what but kurt you've had a
look at this data what do you think of
it do you think it's compelling or or
are you frustrated about the quality or
what what is your opinion i think it's
sad that people
hold these as as evidence of ufos
because i don't think they are
necessarily i think that they're
extremely poor evidence and what about
sightings what about what about
eyewitnesses
that's why all of it has to be looked at
so when someone if someone is to tell me
that bigfoot exists and i ask for
footage and then they show me some
pixelated video i don't think that
that's great evidence for bigfoot now
that in tandem with a variety of stories
from people who we would think of as
credible in any other situation that in
tandem with let's say a rape trial we
would send someone to jail based on two
or three witness testimonies
and yet we have a team of people who are
extremely credible who testify to the
strangeness of this phenomenon and then
we don't we think well perhaps their
eyes are misleading them well i don't
think that's reasonable so i think it's
strange i don't find any single one of
the videos to be compelling i find the
set of videos to be somewhat compelling
that there's something strange happening
but i find the total set of
i i'm putting evidence in scare quotes
here up evidence of ufos to be
interesting and i also don't believe
that we want to believe in ufos i know
that you said that brian i know
well
i want to believe in i want to have
evidence yeah yeah well you also
mentioned that we have this need to
believe in external life and i don't
think that's true for me personally i
hope that all of what's happening with
ufos is false well lee said something
sorry kurt well i'm just afraid of the
implications and i think that anyone who
seriously thinks about this perhaps
should be because it may indicate that
we're not at the top of the food chain
it may mean that we don't mean what we
think we mean in terms of our place in
the universe our purpose even i feel the
same way about the prospects of hell i
don't want to believe in hell not that i
do but i don't want to believe in it in
some ways i don't want to believe in god
in some ways i find comfort in that
consciousness ends so there's so many
beliefs that people say well people have
a need to believe in in god people have
a need to believe in ufos some do some
don't and i think that if you seriously
thought about ufos perhaps
perhaps you would want to believe that
they don't exist when i say ufos i mean
obviously ufos exist the alien life
that's supposedly behind it is what i'm
referring to
yeah well i think that exemplifies why
you're one of the best in the business
kurt and what you do on this on this
channel uh and that you
have uh this you know kind of uh
humility epis epistemological humility
uh but you also have a tenacity and that
is a rare combination um i i think you
know one one nice place maybe to wrap up
and and
you know lee is often
i claim in a good sense you know my
belief fundamentally is that no one's an
atheist
everyone has a religion you know for
some even that don't go to you know
church or synagogue you know that
religion as i documented my first book
losing the nobel prize it is often the
nobel prize and this is kind of a kosher
idol you know that yeah it doesn't cause
that much harm and yeah funding
decisions are made and you know lee's
mentioned it more times than i have
today and it's obviously you know top of
mind for many scientists and and zygozo
hopefully he would win it i don't have
anything against the people that win it
i've interviewed a dozen of them on my
show but on the other hand um you know
there even lack of a religion secularism
um i think that there is a religion of
scientism which is that uh science can
provide meaning and i i'd like to push
back on that i'd like to explore what
lee and you think kurt about this very
notion in other words uh the word
science in in in in
in greek uh means knowledge it doesn't
mean wisdom you know sapien means wisdom
you know one who knows that he knows
sapienism i talk about this lex friedman
on the podcast just came out and look
forward by the way to lee cronin who
inspired me you know to to you know get
connected to lex again uh you know lex
uh hosted lee before me and lee helped
me prepare a lot for my episode because
he was on lex's show and he'll hopefully
have that episode out soon too
allegedly
i can't wait to see that one but you
know i talked about this you know that
that i don't get any meaning from
science i i think scientific science is
intrinsically inherently you know we may
have curiosity and the motto of my
channel is abc always be curious uh but
curiosity and wisdom don't necessarily
go together and i documented many times
you know nobel laureates that were nazis
you know and had great knowledge and
used their knowledge of of chemicals and
you know forefathers you know fritz
haber you know leak
way more engineering but yeah yeah it's
evil you know and he was a jew and his
and his and his uh his zyklon b
eventually led to the gassing of many of
his own family members so anyway don't
look to science for wisdom so if you
can't look into it for wisdom
why do we look to it for meaning
so lee
i can i can give you a quick answer but
maybe kurt it's your show where do you
want to go first yeah
you